do you want an honest yet unpopular
piece of nutrition advice celery juice
only detoxes you because it gives you
the runs first of all celery juice is
like 98 water and water makes you pee
and peeing is one of our body's natural
detoxing mechanisms so just want to
clear that part out there and second if
it speeds things up any faster than
regular water it's because it's so high
in fodmaps that you'll be spending the
morning painting the toilet like a
Jackson Pollock and she not pretty and I
mean like there are less aggressive ways
to do your business for most healthy
people getting enough fiber water and
moving your body is all that is needed
to support your body's natural detoxing
mechanisms which is ironic because
celery juice is devoid of fiber and
listen if you like the taste of celery
juice great you do you but it's not the
magical Elixir that it's being claimed
to be next